toccati oggi mi devi far tornare bambino
voglio liscia come come una questa
roccia però te lo dico non mi fare male
perché tutta una volta i tagli solo
giuro ali dovevo accorciare ma tanto
vengono più a quella ceretto detto poi
lasciò lunghi ma tu sai tutto tu piaci
tanti ma questa non è in te la do
raffreddare un po come la tuta ma ti
pare che mi lasciò la riga ma fatti non
le capisco quale così lasciano la cosa a
metà cioè voglio tira il lavoro lo fai
bene non lo fai a finire altra volta che
me li ha fatti samantha mi sono venuti
tanti di quei punti incarnati dica che
ho dovuto dare la ruspa no la pinzetta
per toglierli o che faccio non mi giro
non me li vuoi fare dietro bene rovai
baffi lascia stare lì voglio fare vi
piacciano così e donna baffuta sempre
piaciuta è un tipo